This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Years ago, I work with my friend Julie Shapiro at the Third Coast International Audio Festival. And for more than a decade, Third Coast hosted a competition for short-form documentaries based on a specific challenge. They were called short docs. We would invite people to make short audio stories inspired by a set of prompts. And we just trusted the fact that if you invite people to make something and give them a little bit of parameters to play with, You know, my mantra is like, it always works. You can always invite people to get creative and they will always respond in some fashion. Over the years, I must have listened to dozens of short docs and hearing them gave me this jolt of inspiration.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。多年前，我和好友朱莉·夏皮罗在“第三海岸国际音频节”共事。十多年来，“第三海岸”一直围绕特定的挑战举办短篇纪录片比赛。它们被称为微型纪录片。我们会邀请大家根据一组提示创作简短的音频故事。我们坚信这样一个事实：如果你邀请大家创作点东西，并给他们一点发挥的空间——你知道，我的座右铭是，这总能奏效。你随时都可以邀请大家发挥创意，他们总会以某种方式做出回应。多年来，我一定听过几十部微型纪录片，听着它们让我感到一阵灵感的冲击。
They were a reminder about what was possible with audio and how the whole medium benefits when there's a place for all kinds of storytelling. However, in recent years, the audio business has changed. Long-form conversation-type podcasts dominate, and it's made it hard. harder for documentary and short-form experimental audio to find a home, which is why Julie Shapiro and her creative partner, John DeLore, created AudioFlux. We thought, you know, everything is longer and longer and longer and longer. So what if we could, you know, create some energy around a short form? So John and I decided to create AudioFlux, which is sort of a new version of the Short Docs
它们提醒着我们，音频究竟能带来多少可能，当各种风格的叙事都能找到一席之地时，整个媒介将从中获得多么巨大的受益。然而，近年来音频行业发生了变化。长篇对话类的播客占据了主导地位，这使得纪录片和实验性短音频很难找到安身之所。正因如此，朱莉·夏皮罗和她的创意搭档约翰·德洛尔共同创立了 AudioFlux。我们当时想，你知道的，内容变得越来越长、越来越长、越来越长、越来越长。那么，如果我们能为短篇形式注入一些活力呢？于是，我和约翰决定创立 AudioFlux，它有点像“微型纪录片
Challenge, but maybe a little bit more for the podcasting age. AudioFlux was recently recognized by the New Yorker as one of the best podcast. of 2025. And I want to share this project because I'm a big fan of what Julie and John are creating. And I want to expand your definition of what a podcast can be. We're going to play some audio flux stories in a bit. But first, I'm going to talk with Julie about how it all works. So let's start off with a bit of an origin story here. How did you and John first arrive at the idea for audio flux? Yeah. So we started in the spring of 2023 talking to each other. John and I had kind of known each other for, known of each other really. We had a lot of people in common because we both
挑战赛”的新版本，但或许更契合播客时代。AudioFlux 最近被《纽约客》评为 2025 年最佳播客之一。我想分享这个项目，因为我非常喜欢朱莉和约翰正在创造的事物。我也想拓展你对播客可能性的定义。稍后我们将播放一些 AudioFlux 的故事。但首先，我将与朱莉聊聊它是如何运作的。让我们从它的起源故事开始吧。你和约翰是如何最初萌生出创作 AudioFlux 的想法的？嗯。所以我们在 2023 年春天开始互相交流。我和约翰其实算得上彼此知道对方。我们有很多共同的朋友，因为我们都有着
had these long histories of working in public radio and coming into podcasting, you know, in its early hey days. And so we were talking in the spring because he had just been let go from a job with a big podcast company and I was in between positions. And we were just talking about how morale seemed really low, low in the creative audio corner of podcasting. And in our community and amongst our friends, the people we kept talking to felt I just like really could sense this industry fatigue, you know, at every turn. And we started thinking about what could we do in this moment together that might reverse some of that or give people something to appreciate, you know, audio for the sake of audio. And this idea for audio flux came out of that kind of motivation to offer
在公共广播工作的漫长经历，并且在播客的早期全盛时期进入了这个行业。所以在那个春天我们聊天，因为他刚被一家大型播客公司解雇，而我正处于两份工作交替的间歇期。我们当时就在讨论，播客中创意音频领域的士气似乎非常非常低落。在我们的社区里以及我们的朋友当中，我们不断交流的人都切实感觉到，在各个方面都能感受到这种行业疲惫感，你知道的。于是我们开始思考，在这个时刻，我们能一起做些什么来扭转这种局面，或者让人们重新体会到音频本身的魅力？AudioFlux 这个想法就源于这种动机，旨在为
something back to the community and also do something that would bring our own spirits up at the same time. So how does it work? Like how do you get people to? do it? How do you set up the structure for the sort of challenge? So twice a year, we run circuits. And for each circuit, we have a different creative partner, like an illustrator or a pet portrait artist or a writer. And it's with that partner that the theme for the circuit and the prompts that we invite people to respond to are design. So it boils down to that formula. And another part of the audio flex design is that each story is only three minutes long. So why three minutes? So we thought three minutes would be inviting enough to convince
社区回馈一些东西，同时也做一些能振奋我们自己精神的事情。那么它是如何运作的呢？比如，你是如何让大家参与进来的？你如何为这种挑战赛搭建结构？因此，我们每年举办两次循环活动。对于每一次循环活动，我们都有不同的创意合作伙伴，比如插画家、宠物肖像艺术家或作家。正是在与这位合作伙伴的合作中，我们设计出了本次循环活动的主题以及我们邀请大家做出回应的提示。所以归根结底就是这样一个公式。AudioFlux 设计的另一个部分是，每个故事的时长只有三分钟。那么为什么要设定为三分钟呢？所以我们认为三分钟足够具有吸引力，能够说服
people to try, to give it a go to participate in the circuits. But it's also like this iconic duration, right? Like three minute pop songs are very popular. And these flux works, we call them flux works, almost end up being like songs or like little pop songs that you can listen to over and over. And there certainly are some that I kind of sing along with when I hear them. So you can do enough in three minutes to make a really compelling, memorable, profound audio story, but it also is not too daunting if you're trying to do something, you know, in a limited amount of time or for the first time. I mean, I think most podcast ads are longer than three minutes at this point. I know. Well, this is our way of protesting against all of the, you know, the, what's happened
人们尝试一下，去参与到这些循环活动中来。但它也具有这种标志性的时长，对吧？就像三分钟的流行歌曲非常受欢迎一样。而这些 flux works——我们称它们为 flux works——几乎最终就像一首歌，或者像你可以一遍又听的小流行歌曲。当然，当我听到某些作品时，我确实会跟着一起哼唱。因此，你完全可以在三分钟内创作出一个非常引人入胜、令人难忘且寓意深远的音频故事，而且如果你试图在有限的时间内或者第一次尝试做点什么时，它也不会显得那么令人望而生畏。我的意思是，我觉得现在大多数播客广告都比三分钟长。我知道。嗯，这也是我们对播客近年来发生的种种变化的一种抗议方式。我只是，我是一个超级，我想，我是一个超级播客粉丝。我制作播客。我听播客。但我有，你知道，我想我们都对行业中发生的一些事情以及那种想象力如何荡然无存感到有些沮丧。
to podcasting in a way. I just, I'm a big, I want, I'm a big podcast fan. I make podcasts. I listen to podcast. But I have, you know, I think we're all a little frustrated with some of the things that have happened in the industry and how the kind of imagination has left the building. So how far along are you with the project? So we've had two banner years, I must say, we have run six different circuits, which means we have partnered with six different creative partners, six different sets of rules, six different themes. And the life cycle of a circuit is that we commission four pieces from producers who we invite and then we do an open call. And then anyone can participate in the open call. And then we pick winners and we present the winners and the commission works at a big live
那么这个项目目前进展到什么阶段了？所以，我必须说，我们已经度过了两个辉煌的年头，我们开展了六个不同的循环活动，这意味着我们已经与六位不同的创意合作伙伴合作，制定了六套不同的规则、六个不同的主题。循环活动的生命周期是这样的：我们向邀请的制作人委约四件作品，然后我们发出公开征集。接着任何人都可以参与公开征集。随后我们挑选出获奖者，并在某个大型现场活动中展示获奖作品和委约作品。
event somewhere. It's really important to us to bring the community together to listen to these pieces. And so we have been always debuting them first in a public setting at a conference or a festival. And then we put them online and now we have the podcast for them to appear in as well. Well, I'm very excited to listen to some of these flux works, as you call them. So let's start with one from the First Circuit of Stories. This one's called The Sound of Silence. Could you tell us about this piece? So our partner for the First Circuit was the incredible artist and illustrator Wendy McNaughton.
将社区聚集在一起聆听这些作品对我们来说非常重要。因此，我们总是首先在会议或节日的公开场合首发它们。然后我们将它们放到网上，现在我们也有了让它们亮相的播客节目。好了，我很兴奋能聆听其中一些被称为 flux works 的作品。那么让我们从第一轮循环故事中的一个开始吧。这个作品叫做《寂静之声》。你能给我们讲讲这个作品吗？所以我们第一轮循环活动的合作伙伴是了不起的艺术家和插画家温迪·麦克诺顿。
And with her, we came up with this theme of letting go. And this was based on a book that she had written and recently published after spending some time with people at the end of their lives. So the book was called How to Say Goodbye. And in talking to Wendy, we thought about a theme that wasn't exactly that, but letting go really touched on the things she was drawing and writing about. And so this was the theme we brought to the producers to work with. And Gregory Warner made this piece called The Sound of Silence, which was about a situation he, his wife found herself in and, you know, touches on letting go, but also really dives into a certain time and place and space in their lives. All right, well, let's hear it. So a few years ago, this thing happened to my wife, Sana.
通过与她合作，我们想出了“放手”（letting go）这个主题。这是基于她写的一本书，是她在陪伴临终之人一段时间后最近出版的。所以这本书叫做《如何告别》（How to Say Goodbye）。在与温迪交谈时，我们构思了一个主题，虽然不完全是那样，但“放手”确实触及了她当时所绘制和书写的内容。这就是我们带给制作人们去创作的主题。格雷戈里·华纳制作了这件名为《寂静之声》的作品，讲的是他和妻子经历的一种情况，这既触及了放手，也真正深入到了他们生活中的特定时间和地点与空间。好吧，那我们来听听吧。所以几年前，我的妻子萨娜身上发生了这样一件事。
She'd be meditating or reading a book, and she'd hear a sound. Do... A kind of ghostly tone, just above and behind her right ear. As though someone were reading over my shoulder with me and delighting in it along with me. An odd but delightful thing at a time when delight was in short supply. The pandemic's first spring. Sana's mind on high alert, schools closed,
她会在冥想或读书时，听到一种声音。嘟……一种幽灵般的音调，就在她右耳上方偏后的位置。就像有人在和我一起越过我的肩膀阅读，并和我一起为此感到快乐。在一个快乐供不应求的时期，这是一种奇怪但令人愉快的体验。大流行的第一个春天。萨娜的神经高度紧绷，学校关闭，
death and doom on the news, one tiny home office for the two of us. I was trying to get work done and you were always on the phone in interviews. But the tone was like a place that I could go to. It was like a dome I could enter that was almost insulated by static. It let me let go of all this high cortisol shit. And the tone could also tune her in to the most everyday moments, our kid practicing piano. Every note was almost like a pebble thrown into a lake in such a way that it created these musical ripples.
新闻里充斥着死亡与末日，我们两人共用一个微型家庭办公室。我当时正试图完成工作，而你在采访中总是在打电话。但那个音调就像是一个我可以去的地方。它就像一个我可以进入的穹顶，几乎被静电所隔绝。它让我得以放下所有这些高皮质醇的破事。这个音调还能让她调谐到最日常的时刻，我们的孩子在练习钢琴。每一个音符都几乎像是被投进湖中的一颗石子，激起了层层音乐般的涟漪。
Well, you never told me this. Well, because, you know, it wasn't what I thought it was. The tone, not what she thought it was. Deep inside your inner ear are these special hair cells, cilia, that float in fluid like a field of seaweed. They're tuned to different frequencies. if some of these little hairs are damaged by loud noise or by a virus. Now that frequency or that range of frequencies that used to be there is not there anymore.
好吧，你从来没跟我说过这个。嗯，因为，你知道的，那并不是我以为的那样。这个音调，并非她所想的那样。在你的内耳深处，有这些特殊的毛细胞——纤毛，它们像一片海草一样漂浮在液体中。它们对不同的频率敏感。如果其中一些小毛细胞受到噪音或病毒的破坏。那么原本存在的那个频率或那个频率范围就不复存在了。
Dr. Jim Henry is a pioneer of research in Tinnitus. And the brain is in a steady state most of the time. So now it's got this loss. The brain, he says, can respond to this loss of hearing by overcompensating, by upping its activity. Filling in the missing frequencies, like a phantom limb, Tinnitus is the sound of the brain's refusal to let go of what it once had. Yeah. Yeah.
吉姆·亨利博士是耳鸣研究的先驱。大脑在大多数时候都处于稳定状态。所以现在它有了这种缺失。他说，大脑可以通过过度补偿来应对这种听力损失，也就是提高其活动水平。填补缺失的频率，就像幻肢一样，耳鸣就是大脑拒绝放手它曾经拥有过的一切的声音。是的。是的。
I got my diagnosis and I cried on my way home. I always had it in the back of my mind like, yeah, you could be reaching enlightenment or you could just be going deaf. And I just chose to believe in the former. She knows now it's a symptom. But still, these days when she's reading or concentrating on something. beautiful. When words turn into images in your mind, the tones come back. For her, the tones are still a sign that she's attained some mental quiet. She's paying attention to what is here, even if the sound that she's actually listening to is just the brain's song of grief for what is gone.
我拿到了诊断结果，在回家的路上哭了。我的脑海深处一直有这种想法：是的，你可能是达到了顿悟，或者你可能只是在变聋。而我只是选择相信前者。她现在知道这是一种症状。不过，如今当她阅读或专注于某些美好的事物时。当文字在你的脑海中变成图像时，这些音调又会回来了。对她来说，这些音调仍然是她获得某种精神宁静的标志。她关注着眼前的现实，哪怕她实际在听的声音，其实只是大脑为逝去之物所唱的悲伤之歌。
So that was the sound of silence by Gregory Warner. It's a beautiful piece. And what I love about it in particular is like, I know Gregory Warner's work from NPR. He was a long time, you know, foreign journalist did rough translation, the NPR podcast. And this allows you to get a different side of what he can create. That is so important to us to give, you know, we want to give brand new producers an opportunity to do something, but also to give more experienced people the opportunity to do something else than they usually do. And we felt that with Gregory too. I mean, he is a masterful storyteller at all durations, but we really felt like he could get a little more personal with this and bring his like signature NPR style to this little flux work. And it's just so beautiful. Yeah. So let's play another piece. This is from circuit number two and the theme is listening with. And can you describe this theme and how you came to it?
这就是格雷戈里·华纳的《寂静之声》。这是一部美丽的杰作。我特别喜欢它的一点是——我知道格雷戈里·华纳在 NPR 的作品。他长期担任外国记者，制作了 NPR 的播客《粗略翻译》（Rough Translation）。而这让你看到了他所能创作的内容的另一面。这对于我们来说非常重要，我们不仅希望给全新崭露头角的制作人提供机会去尝试新鲜事物，也希望给更有经验的人提供机会去创作他们平时不常做的事。我们在格雷戈里身上也感受到了这一点。我的意思是，他在各种时长的叙事中都是一位大师级的讲故事者，但我们真的觉得他可以通过这个作品变得更具个人色彩，并将他标志性的 NPR 风格带入到这个微型的 flux work 中。而且它真的是太美了。好了，让我们播放另一首作品。这是来自第二循环，主题是“伴随倾听”（listening with）。你能描述一下这个主题以及你们是怎么想到它的吗？
Oh, yeah. We were inspired by the film 32 sounds by the wonderful filmmaker Sam Green. And in that, that film is a scene with Anaa Lockwood, who's this very accomplished field recordist, sound designer, composer, sound experimentalists. And she has this theory of listening with the world, instead of listening to the world or at the world. So we grabbed that theme from Sam's film and invited producers to draw from that theme of listening with as they tell a story and also to think about everyday sounds in their environments. And so what's this piece that we're going to listen to from this circuit? Well, this piece is actually, it's called In Between Silence by the British producer Talia Augustidis. And as Talia thought about the story she wanted to tell, she was
哦，是的。我们受到了出色的电影制作人萨姆·格林的电影《32种声音》（32 sounds）的启发。在这部电影中有一个场景，出场的是安娜·洛克伍德，她是一位非常有成就的田野录音师、声音设计师、作曲家和声音实验主义者。她提出了这样一种理论：与世界一同倾听（listening with the world），而不是去听世界（listening to the world）或向世界倾听（listening at the world）。所以我们从萨姆的电影中抓住了这个主题，并邀请制作人们在讲述故事时从“伴随倾听”这个主题中汲取灵感，同时去思考他们环境中的日常声音。那么我们要听来自这个循环的这首作品是什么呢？嗯，这个作品实际上叫做《寂静之间》（In Between Silence），由英国制作人塔莉娅·奥古斯蒂迪斯创作。当塔莉娅思考她想要讲述的故事时，她一直在
thinking about the sounds around her versus the sounds that other people are hearing and are maybe forced to hear. So at the time, the war in Gaza was in full force. And she wanted to think about the situation for people living in Gaza and their sonic environments. And so, And so she sort of took on the role of helping people living in that environment talk about what they were hearing on a daily basis. We must leave this country and look for another country to live. I always remember the in a coma that you've got to keep in London and said me how you're to quit up in Pekinghaven.
思考她周围的声音，以及其他人正在听到、甚至可能被迫听到的声音。当时，加沙战争正如火如荼地进行。她想要思考加沙居民的处境以及他们的声音环境。所以，于是她有点扮演起了帮助生活在那里的环境中的人们讲述他们日常所听到的声音的角色。我们必须离开这个国家，寻找另一个国家居住。我一直记得你在伦敦获得居留权的方式。我一直记得你如何在白金汉宫外写作。我在巴黎寻找类似的东西。你觉得呢？加沙已经结束了，我的朋友。加沙已经结束了，我的朋友。不幸的是，我们甚至无法在其中呼吸。加沙的无人机感觉如此熟悉，以至于它们赢得了一个绰号。
I always remember how you obtained residency in London. How you used to write outside a Bukhian palace. I'm looking for something similar in Paris. What do you think? Gaza is over, my friend. Gaza is over, my friend. And unfortunately, we will not be able to even breathe in it. The drones feel so familiar in Gaza that they've earned a nickname.
赞纳纳（Zanana）。意思是令人讨厌的嗡嗡声，一种已经持续了20多年的嗡嗡声，一种在暴力加剧期间变得近乎持续不断的嗡嗡声，一种代表着监视以及导弹袭击迫在眉睫的可能性的嗡嗡声。你试图让事情照常进行，所以你试图做饭，你试图在电视上观看能振奋你精神的内容，某些声音会穿透这种试图营造正常状态的企图，然后随着时间推移，你对这种声音习以为常了
Zanana. It means an annoying buzzing, a buzzing which has been present for over 20 years, a buzzing which becomes near constant during periods of increased violence, a buzzing which represents surveillance and the looming possibility of a missile strike. You try to just get on with things normally, so you try to make food, you try to kind of watch things on TV that will uplift you, Certain sounds would penetrate that kind of attempt to create normality and then over time you become habituated to the sound
但随后你经历的焦虑程度可能会导致对声音含义产生更多偏执。你的大脑会想，哦，它稍微有点不同。那东西有些不同。但可能并非如此。这只是试图去预测未来的一种尝试。是的，这是一个有趣的问题：加沙在两次轰炸之间，或者在无人机和火箭弹之间等等的寂静时期，
but then the level of anxiety that you're experiencing can then lead to more paranoia about the meaning of the sound. Your sort of mind kind of thinks, oh, it was slightly different. There was something different about that. But it probably wasn't. It's just an attempt to kind of try to predict the future. Yeah, it's an interesting question whether the periods of silence in Gaza between bombings or between drones and rockets and so on
本身是不是就不算寂静，因为它是一种不祥的预兆。没有飞机的声音。有休战协议。但这个休战协议只是暂时的。但这个休战协议只是暂时的。只有四天。哦，上帝，我祈祷这次休战能改善我们的状况。我发誓，我很开心。
was in itself not silence because it's a foreboding. There are no sounds of planes. There's a truce. But this truce is only temporary. But this truce is only temporary. Only four days. Oh, God, I pray that this truce will better our conditions. I swear, I'm happy.
我很高兴，对不起，我很高兴。我发誓，没有了赞纳纳的声音，生活就像这样美好。这就是《寂静之间》。你知道的，当你把这件作品与格雷戈里·华纳的故事放在一起或相提并论时，你就会得到关于寂静的这两种不同的沉思。塔莉娅的故事能唤起你怎样的感受？我认为 AudioFlux 能够达到的奇迹之一，
I'm a lot of it, I'm sorry, I'm glad. I swear, life is beautiful like this without the sounds of Zanana. So that was in between silence. And, you know, when you hear this piece together with or next to Gregory Warner's story, you get these two different meditations on silence. What does Tali's story evoke for you? I think one of the miracles of what AudioFlux gets to
就是有如此多的方式来讲述故事。我的意思是，这是两个不同的循环，有着两个不同的起点，但它们却共同拥有着“寂静”这个概念，以及某种寂静的表象或其缺乏。而且，你知道，你发现的一件事，真正迷人的是，这些 flux works 有时如何在同一个循环内或跨循环之间进行对话。
is that there's so many ways to tell stories. I mean, these were two different circuits with two different starting points, but yet they have in common this idea of silence and some manifestation of silence or lack thereof. And, you know, one thing you find, and what's really fascinating is how sometimes the flux works will talk to each other within a circuit or across circuits.
你知道，归根结底，我们在六个循环中创作了 300 多个 flux works。而且它展现出一种对讲故事的无限可能性，即使在这么短的时长里也是如此。所以你挑选了两位做过大量其他工作的制作人，每个人都来面对这个三分钟的挑战或练习。而且，你知道的，我们通过塔莉娅讲述故事的方式对她有了很多了解。我们通过格雷戈里透露关于他妻子的内容对他有了很多了解。但是，你知道的，他们在形式上非常不同，风格也不同。但我认为，它们同样令人难忘，只是出于非常不同的原因。休息过后，我和朱莉将分享更多 AudioFlux 的故事。
And, you know, ultimately, you know, we've had 300 plus flux works made across the six circuits. And it's just there's such a boundless possibility for storytelling, even in this short duration. So you take, you know, two producers who have done a lot of other work, each approaching this three-minute challenge or exercise. And, you know, we learn a lot about Talia through how she tells that story. We learn a lot about Gregory through what he reveals about his wife. But, you know, they're very different in form, different in style. But I think, equally memorable, but just for very different reasons. After the break, Julie and I share a few more audio flux stories.
请继续收听。欢迎回来，我是朱莉·夏皮罗。好的。那我为你准备了另一个 flux work。这个来自第四循环。主题是“第一次”或“初次经历”。我们的合作伙伴是杰森·雷诺兹，他曾写过一本关于一段非常特殊的初次经历的 YA（青少年）小说。所以我们从那个话题中汲取灵感，邀请大家向我们讲述关于第一件事或第一次经历的故事。
Stay tuned. And we're back with Julie Shapiro. All right. So I have another flux work ready for you. This one is from Circuit 4. The theme was firsts or first times. Our partner was Jason Reynolds, who had written a young adult novel about a very special first time. And so we drew from that topic and invited people to tell us about first things or first times.
这就是凯特琳·海尔伍德和艾伦·吉芬斯基创作的《B面的幽灵》。好的，这个我还没听过。那我们来看看，然后在听完后我们再聊聊它。现在在收音机里播出了。好的，在这里闲逛。是5。3，2，1，你上场了。那是 2001 年。我 16 岁，也许 15 岁，我坐在我古老笨重的音响面前的卧室地板上，听着我的 CD——那是 90 年代热门音乐剧《吉屋出租》（Rent）的原版百老汇演员录音。我总是在听《吉屋出租》。百老汇明星们的波希米亚歌词充斥着我的双耳。我想离开郊区，
And this is The Ghost on Side B by Caitlin Halewood and Alan Giffinsky. Okay, I have not heard this one. So let's check it out, and we'll talk about it on the other side. It's on the radio now. Okay, hanged out here. It's five. Three, two, one, you're on. It's 2001. I'm 16, maybe 15, and I'm sitting on my bedroom floor in front of my ancient clunky stereo, listening to my CD of the original Broadway cast recording of the 1990s hit musical Rent. I'm always listening to Rent. Broadway stars fill my ears with lyrics of Bohemia. I want to get out of the sub-90s. I'm always listening to Rent. I'm always listening to Rent. Broadway stars fill my ears with lyrics of Bohemia. I want to get out of the
去创作艺术，去做一个女同性恋，不穿科尔百货（Kohls）买的衣服。我决定必须把这张 CD 录制到磁带上，这样我就可以在坐妈妈的小型货车去学校的路上听了，因为我们的车里没有 CD 播放器。所以我拿了一盘在客厅里找到的空白磁带。我把磁带放进卡式录音座。我将其与 CD 的开始同步，然后按下录音键。第二天早上，我跳上副驾驶座。我把磁带放进磁带播放器里，然后我跟着哼唱起来，一切都是那么欢快，满脑子都是《吉屋出租》、《吉屋出租》、《吉屋出租》、《吉屋出租》。然后，毫无预兆地，磁带跳到了另一面——B面，一个男人的声音传了出来。早上好，609号房，我们说了什么？
suburbs and make art and be a lesbian and not wear clothes from coals. I decide that I must record this CD to a tape so I can listen to it in my mom's minivan on the way to school because we don't have a CD player in the car. So I take a blank tape I find in the living room. I put the cassette in my tape deck. I sink it with the start of the CD and I press record. The next morning, I hop in the passenger seat. I put the tape in the cassette player, and I'm singing along, and it's all bouncy, and rent, rent, rent, rent, rent. Then, without warning, the tape skips to the other side, the B side, and a man's voice comes on. Good morning, 609, we said what?
我母亲说，你从哪弄来的这磁带？我说，这是什么磁带？你是不是从客厅的箱子里拿的这磁带？这个磁带里的男人是谁？她说，这磁带不是空白磁带。这磁带里的是你父亲。我以前从来没听过这个声音。或者如果我听过，我也记不得了。
And my mother says, where did you get this tape? And I say, what is this tape? Did you get this tape from the box in the living room? Who is this man on this tape? and she says, this tape is not a blank tape. This tape is your father. I'd never heard this voice before. Or if I did, I didn't remember.
1987 年 7 月 18 日，西德（Sid）去他担任 DJ 的乡村广播电台上班，然后就再也没有回家。我当时两岁。他 40 岁。是心脏病发作。但他就在这里。
On July 18, 1987, Sid went to work at the country radio station where he was a DJ, and then did not come home. I was two. He was 40. It was a heart attack. But here he was.
西德·伍德（Sid Wood）在乡村 105 WFMB 电台，就像他一直藏在电波里一样。第一次听到我父亲的声音并不像看一张照片。它感觉像触摸。带有缠绕在塑料磁带盒中的磁带盘的小卷轴。这是一个入口。你得当雷达天气。你就在那儿。
Sid Wood on Country 105 WFMB, like he'd been hiding in the airwaves all along. Hearing my dad for the first time didn't feel like looking at a photograph. It felt like touch. Tiny spools with reels of magnetic tape coiled into a plastic cassette. This was a portal. You have to be radar weather. There you are.
我在这里，在空间与时间的声学轴心上。好吧。你们大家还要再待一会儿还是怎样？很高兴认识你。哇，这太棒了。在它结束后，我通常需要稍微呼吸一下，才能真正开口说话。对啊，对啊，这个，嗯，我其实很好奇。你听完后的第一印象是什么？
Here I am at a sonic axis of space and time. Okay. You all going to stick around for a little longer or what? Nice to meet you. Wow, that is so good. I often have to breathe a little bit after it ends before I can really talk. Yeah, yeah, this one, well, I'm actually curious. What's your first impression coming out of it?
我的第一感受是，世界上有我录下的声音的那么多小时。我经常和我的孩子们想到这一点，我没有上一代人声音的很多资料，甚至连他们的照片都不多，而现在的孩子们将拥有多得多。拥有这样一件东西是多么罕见和特别，特别是录制在磁带上的广播，真的是——真的是别有一番滋味。我以前经常把广播录到磁带上。所以我发现这一切都非常、非常神奇。我不知道人们是否能理解——考虑到如今你口袋里随时都有录音和记录设备——拥有某人的声音是多么特别。然后是这一切纯粹的巧合，以及在不知情的情况下差点失去这一切的危险。这一切对我来说都充满了情感。
My first thing is that there's so many hours of my recorded voice in the world. And I think about this a lot with my kids and how I don't have a lot of the previous generation, you know, of the sound of their voice or even photographs of them and how much more kids will have. And how rare and special this is to have this thing, especially radio recorded onto a tape is really is really something else. I used to record radio onto tape. And so I just find it all very, very kind of magical. And I don't know if you know if people will understand with the fact that you have a recording device and a documenting device in your pocket at all times these days, how special it is to have the sound of someone's voice. And then the pure chance of it all and then the near disaster of losing it all, too, without knowing. All of it is just like it's full of emotion for me.
是的，我真的很能体会那种奇迹感。实际上，星象连成一线，让她为凯特琳发现了这一点。凯特琳·海尔伍德和艾伦·吉芬斯基共同创作了这件作品。它真的很受大众欢迎。我的意思是，我们同样喜爱所有的 flux works，但这一件确实让人产生某种共鸣。我认为这与你刚才谈到的一些事情有关，比如听到某人的声音的力量。
Yeah, I can really appreciate that sort of the wonder of it all. that actually the stars aligned for her to discover this for Caitlin. Caitlin Halewood and Alan Giffinsky made this piece together. And it's really, it's been a crowd favorite. I mean, we love all of the flux works equally, but this one really people respond to in a certain way. And I think it has to do with some of the things you were talking about, like the power of hearing somebody.
所以凯特琳保留了这些录音。我认为她找到了一种非常诗意的方式，让我们更接近她、她自己以及发现她父亲的故事。我真的对这件作品中不同的色调和情感印象深刻。它很有趣。带有一点神秘感。艾伦的声音设计很美。你沉浸在磁带的声音中。而且，你知道的，对于任何在成长过程中播放过盒式磁带或玩过盒式磁带的人来说，这都是如此熟悉。还有那句台词：“时间和空间的声学轴心”，我喜欢以那种思考、惊叹和推测的地点来结尾。是的，这件作品，我认为仅仅三分钟就已经是完美的了。
And so Caitlin had these recordings. And I think she found a very, poetic way to bring us closer to her and her and the story of discovering her father. And I'm really struck by the different tones and emotions in this piece. It's funny. It's a little mysterious. The sound designed by Alan is beautiful. You are immersed in the sound of like cassette. And, you know, it's just, it's so familiar to anyone who ever played gazettes or played with cassettes growing up. and then that line, a sonic axis of time and place, time and space, I love ending in that sort of place of thinking and wondering and speculating. And yeah, this piece, I think just the three minutes are perfect.
但我得说，这里有一个更大的故事，他们实际上正试图讲述更大的故事。所以有时 flux works 可以成为人们想要深入探讨的更大想法的试验场，他们正在围绕凯特琳探索她父亲的经历的寻找，开发一整部节目。所以这一切都从这里开始，但随后，你知道的，它能够而且确实从这里延续下去。既然我们谈到了“第一次”这个循环，让我们来听听《初语》（First Words）。你能描述一下这个作品吗？是的。我应该说的一件事是，许多 flux works 都围绕着家庭关系展开。所以接下来的这件作品也与父爱、语言和听到声音有关。但这是一个截然不同的故事，以截然不同的方式讲述。接下来我们将听到彼得·兰斯顿（Peter Langstanton）的《初语》。这基本上是一部关于他儿子生命头两年的延时摄影风格的作品。
But I will say there's a bigger story here and they're actually trying to tell the bigger story. So sometimes fluxworks can be like testing grounds for bigger ideas that people want to dive into and they're developing a whole show around Caitlin's. sort of search to learn more about her father. So it all starts here, but then, you know, it can and does go on from here. So while we're on this circuit of first, let's hear first words. Can you describe this piece? Yeah. One thing I should say is so many of the flux works revolve around family relationships. And so this next piece is also has to do with fatherhood and language and hearing voice. But it's a very, very different story told in a very different way. So we're going to hear first words by Peter Langstanton. And this is basically a kind of time-lapse piece about the first two years of his son's life.
让我们从家庭录像开始吧，那是我爸爸用肩膀扛着摄像机拍的，裤子短得有点危险。这是另一段家庭录像。这个是我拍的。我们做两次深呼吸。一。好吧。好吧。这是我儿子出生的确切时刻。
Let's start with the home movies, the one's my dad made, with a camcorder on his shoulder and shorts that were dangerously short. Here's another home video. I made this one. Let's do two breaths. One. Okay. Okay. This is the exact moment my son was born.
嗨，有什么新鲜事？哦，天哪，你好。哦天哪。这是我对他说第一句话。嗨，亲爱的。这也是我对狗狗说的话。嗨，亲爱的，谁是个好女孩？谁是个好女孩？
Hi, what a new? Oh, my goodness, hello. Oh my God. These are the first words I said to him. Hi, sweetie. It's also what I say to dogs. Hi, sweetie, who's a good girl? Who's a good girl?
总之。哦天哪。这也是我儿子第一次使用他的声音。什么？什么？但我真的不知道学说话到底需要多长时间。我要发出一些声音。我能听听你说话吗？
Anyway. Oh my god. And this is the first time my son ever used his voice. What? What? But I really had no idea just how long it takes to talk. I'm going to make some sounds. Can I hear you talk?
或者小小的肋骨。梅尔文（Melvin），你今天早上有什么想说的吗？在很长一段时间里，我们什么都没说。我们必须找到变通办法，寻找其他沟通方式。学说话的部分花了很长时间。我叫什么名字？想象一下，来了一个新室友，但在头两年里你们不能互相说话。我们来洗洗你的脚。
Or tiny little ribs. Melvin, do you have anything to say this morning? For the longest time, we say nothing at all. We have to find workarounds, other ways to communicate. The talking part takes forever. What's my name? Imagine a new roommate, but you can't talk to each other for the first two years. Let's wash your feet.
脚。你的脚趾在哪儿？等待是如此漫长。就在那儿。你担心他可能永远不会说话了。但随后呢？垃圾车说，哔，哔，哔。哔，哔。
Feet. Where are your toes? The weight is so long. Right there. You worry he'll never be able to talk at all. But then? The garbage truck said, beep, beep, beep. Beep, beep.
它从我们房子旁边开过，然后说，哔，哔。哔。嘿，阿尔文（Alvin）。你能说“饼干”（Cracker）吗？Carre。你能再说一遍吗？对不起。阿尔文，你能说“割草机”（lawnmower）吗？
It went right by our house and it said, beep, beep. Beep. Hey, Alvin. Can you say Cracker? Carre. Can you say it again? Sorry. Alvin, can you say lawnmower?
不，妈妈。哇。你能再说一遍“饼干”吗？不。然后突然之间你说出“饼干”？饼干。这一切发生得很快。老麦克唐纳有皮疹。
No, mom. Wow. Can you say Cracker again? No. Then all of a sudden you say Cracker? Cracker. It happens quickly. Old McDonald had a rash.
它发生得如此之快，让人心碎。越来越大。越来越大。你意识到由于自己的不耐烦，
It happened so fast, it breaks your heart. Bigger and bigger. And bigger. And you realize because of your impatience, You were missing what was right in front of you. What's my name? So this one, like, you know, any parent who hears this just kind of loses it. Yeah, relatable.
你错过了就在你眼前的东西。我叫什么名字？所以这个作品，你知道的，任何听到这个的父母都会直接崩溃。是的，很有共鸣。
I mean, yeah, it's very relatable for anyone who's lived with kids learning language. Yeah. You just miss those sounds. There's a lot of stuff that's documented. There's so many pictures. But I really do miss the, you know, the personalities. You know, there's still something there. and, you know, my 19-year-olds, but, like, you know, expressed through that the squeeze box of that tiny little voice, you know what I mean?
我是说，是的，对于任何和学习语言的孩子生活在一起的人来说，这非常有共鸣。是的。你只是错过了那些声音。有很多东西都被记录了下来。有很多照片。但我真的很想念那些，你知道的，个性。你知道，那里仍然有些东西，你知道的，我 19 岁的孩子，但是，你知道，通过那个小声音的手风琴表达出来，你知道我的意思吗？
It's like, is this something I actually, I miss a lot. And hearing the development, you know, it doesn't seem, it's like sort of when you're in the moment, you don't notice it, but when you hear the syllables become words, become emotional, you know, utterances, it's, it's so powerful. And remarkable. And it seems, you know, incredible that we learn language at all. But yet we do. Okay, so there's one more flux works that we want to share here. And this one is from your latest circuit, circuit number six.
就像，这是我其实很怀念的东西。听到发展的过程，你知道，这似乎不像——当你身处其中时，你不会注意到它，但当你听到音节变成词语，变成充满情感的呢喃时，它是如此强大。而且非凡。我们居然能学会语言，这似乎是不可思议的。但我们确实学会了。好吧，这里还有最后一个我们想要分享的 flux work。这个来自你最新的循环，即第六循环。
What was the theme for this one? Okay, we just finished Circuit 6. The theme was Creative Tension. And our partner in this theme and circuit was Lorna Hamilton Brown, who has become known as the Banksy of Knitting in the Fabricard Circles. So I know, I know. Well, quite an honor and she has definitely earned it. Lourna explores all kinds of social justice issues through her art. And her art is mostly knitting, crocheting, working with fabrics. She's also a teacher and an activist and an educator. But we were really lucky to meet her and work with her for the circuit. And so the theme was creative tension. And we asked people to include the sound, like a repetitive sound in the, flux work. It is a nod to kind of the repetitive motion of knitting and handy work. And then we also, I thought this was really fun. Another prompt was to give your story a color, which is like really
这次的主题是什么？好吧，我们刚刚完成了第六循环。主题是“创意张力”（Creative Tension）。我们在这次主题和循环中的合作伙伴是洛娜·汉密尔顿·布朗（Lorna Hamilton Brown），她在针织和纤维艺术界被称为“针织界的班克西”。所以我知道，我知道。嗯，这真是个莫大的荣誉，她绝对实至名归。洛娜通过她的艺术探讨了各种社会正义问题。而她的艺术主要是针织、钩针编织、使用面料。她还是一位老师、活动家和教育工作者。但我们真的很幸运能遇到她并为这个循环与她合作。所以主题是创意张力。我们要求人们在 flux work 中加入声音，比如一种重复的声音。这是对针织和手工活重复动作的一种致敬。然后我们还——我觉得这个真的很有趣。另一个提示是给你的故事赋予一种颜色，这其实
nonsense also, but it was very fun to say like what color does your story sound like at the end of it. So that was also a nod to kind of the yarn and different colors of yarn and a sort of synesthetic sense that Lorna has when she hears music and thinks of patterns. So those are the prompts and the theme. And the piece we're going to hear is called Red Card and the color is red. It's by a couple of producers Vivian Schutz and Laura Rojas-Apante. And the thing that is really notable to me about this one is as much as Fluxworks can be personal and artistic and talk about big abstract ideas, they can also very clearly document the world around us and things happening now. And they really pulled that off with this piece. All right, let's hear it. It's called
也很无厘头，但最后说出你的故事听起来是什么颜色真的非常有趣。所以这也是对纱线和不同颜色的纱线的一种致敬，也是洛娜在听到音乐和思考图案时拥有的一种联觉感。这就是那些提示和主题。我们要听的作品叫做《红牌》（Red Card），颜色是红色。它由两位制作人维维安·舒茨（Vivian Schutz）和劳拉·罗哈斯-阿潘特（Laura Rojas-Apante）创作。对我而言，这一件作品特别引人注目的一点是：尽管 Fluxworks 可以具有个人色彩、艺术感并谈论宏大的抽象概念，但它们也可以非常清晰地记录我们周围的世界以及正在发生的事情。而他们在这件作品中确实做到了这一点。好的，让我们听听看。它叫
Red Card. The cards, the ones that we make, are about the size of a business card. About two inches by three inches. Sort of a heavy piece of red paper. And since January, we've made 110,000 of them. I tend to carry a stack of cards with me. Usually in Spanish, because that's a second language for me. I will hand them to people and say in Spanish, this is about your constitutional rights. This is about your constitutional rights. There's information on what to do with immigration, with the police, with whomever. He gave us cards week by week that we put
《红牌》。这些卡片——我们制作的那些——大约有商业名片那么大。大约两英寸乘三英寸。有点像一张厚重的红纸。自 1 月以来，我们已经制作了 11 万张。我倾向于随身携带一叠卡片。通常是西班牙语的，因为那是我的第二语言。我会把它们递给人们并用西班牙语说，这是关于你的宪法权利。这是关于你的宪法权利。上面有关于如何应对移民局、警察或任何人的信息。他一周接一周地给我们卡片，我们把它们放在
on this plane at the market. Most of the people that would come by take them, especially the Hispanic community, and others would actually take it to give to others that they knew. It says, I do not wish to speak with you. Answer your questions or sign. Hand you any documents based on my Fifth Amendment rights. You now have that card on you. No, open the door.
市场上这个飞机上。大多数路过的人都会拿走，尤其是西班牙裔社区，其他人实际上也会拿去送给他们认识的其他上面写着：我不想跟你说话。回答你的问题或签字。根据我的第五修正案权利，向你递交任何文件。你现在身上带着那张卡。不，开门。
Know what by law will protect you. I do not give you permission. I do not give you permission to enter my home. You come to this country for a better life. Once you are able to apply and to the legal status, you then do it. Applying is a very costly, process, but my folks they had applied. If it wasn't for us doing that, we wouldn't be able to be selling flowers in New York City seven days out of the week and put 26 people
了解法律将如何保护你。我不给你许可。我不给你许可进入我的家。你为了更好的生活来到这个国家。一旦你能够申请并获得合法身份，你就会去申请。申请是一个非常昂贵的过程，但我的父母他们已经申请了。如果不是我们这样做，我们就无法在纽约市一周七天卖花，并通过两个过境为家庭谋生的人，让 26 个人
on payroll because of two people going across the border for their family. The cards themselves, they're premised on the fact that somebody will read them and obey the law. And at some point, that is not. going to be true. You have a red card that it's a piece of cardboard and the other person has a rifle and handcuffs. We know of many neighbors who, because of all of these efforts, they didn't open the door and they don't open the door still.
在薪资名单上。这些卡片本身的前提是，有人会读它们并遵守法律。而在某些时候，那将不再成立。你手里拿着一张红牌，那是一张纸板，而另一个人拿着步枪和手铐。我们知道许多邻居，由于所有这些努力，他们没有开门，而且现在依然不开门。
And that is one of the reasons why I started to arrest people in the courtrooms. As an academic, as an activist, a scholar, I think that the red card is a beautiful symbol. But at the same time, to me, it is also kind of an index of how tiny, how little, how fragile our rights are. It's like such a little thing and that the most fundamental rights can be reading a little card like that. It's kind of telling, right? As a printmaker, what I can do is print something for you. And within my own art, I can tackle issues. I can do these things.
这也是我开始在法庭上逮捕人们的原因之一。作为一名学者、活动家、学者，我认为红牌是一个美丽的象征。但与此同时，对我来说，它也是我们的权利有多么微小、多么渺小、多么脆弱的一个指标。这就像一件很小的事情，而最基本的权利竟然需要靠阅读这样一张小卡片来维护。这挺说明问题的，对吧？作为一名版画家，我能做的是为你印制一些东西。在我的艺术创作中，我可以解决问题。我可以做这些事情。
But when those things are not effective, I don't know what to do. I mean, this one is like kind of the most 99PI story. Like it tells a full story of the world that we're in through a small object. I love stories like that. Yeah. And, you know, just a couple of those lines that really bring home the situation that we're reading a lot about in the news, but that just that personal window into actual people's experience of the car, having the cards and, you know, dispersing them. And we also thought the theme, creative tension for me was also a moment of refurb.
但当这些事情不起作用时，我不知道该怎么办。我的意思是，这一首有点像是最具 99PI（99%隐形）风格的故事。就像它通过一个小物件讲述了我们所处世界的完整故事。我喜欢这样的故事。是的。而且，你知道，仅仅是其中几行台词，就真正把我们在新闻中读到的大量情况生动地展现出来，但那只是通往人们持有卡片并分发卡片的实际经历的个人窗口。我们还认为，对我来说，“创意张力”这个主题也是一个反思的时刻，
reflection as artists and creative people, like, what do we do in this moment where things around us seem chaotic and what is an artist's role in this moment? So there's sort of this meta notion of creative tension, which the printmaker elaborates or is very eloquent about talking about what can he do in this moment. So this piece speaks to all of the themes wrapped up in the overarching theme of creative tension. When I first heard it, I didn't know the audio flux prompt. And I was so struck by the rhythm of the incantation. of rights. It's really amazing because it's like in speaking them, like it's what sort of gives them their power and like rights not used or rights lost and speaking them like keeps them in use. And I just think it's amazing to hear. Yeah. And speaking them, the people that they are for and are about speaking them. So this is a document that is about community and about all the people. And then you're actually hearing hearing it read by some of these people. It's so satisfying and is so powerful. So, I mean, I hope that we've just blown people's minds in the best way possible because, like, I have noticed it too, like in listening to podcasts. I love podcasts. I listen to
作为艺术家和创意人士，在这个周围一切似乎都混乱的时刻我们该做些什么，艺术家的角色又是什么？所以这有一种关于创意张力的元概念，版画家对此进行了阐述，或者非常雄辩地谈论了他在此时此刻能做什么。因此，这件作品呼应了包裹在“创意张力”这一总体主题之中的所有主题。当我第一次听到它时，我并不知道 AudioFlux 的提示。我被那些权利的魔咒的节奏深深震撼了。这真的很神奇，因为在说出它们的过程中——正是这种宣读赋予了它们力量，未使用的权利或失去的权利，而大声说出来能让它们保持使用状态。我只是觉得听到这个太棒了。是的。通过大声说出来——那些权利属于的人以及关于他们的人大声说出来。所以这是一个关于社区、关于所有人的纪实。然后你实际上听到其中一些人朗读它。它是如此令人满足，如此强大。所以，我的意思是，我希望我们刚刚以最好的方式震撼了人们的心灵——因为，就像我注意到的一样——在听播客时。我喜欢播客。我听
chatty podcasts. I listen to three hour long podcasts. I've made and contributed to that particular art form. But it was just so nice to remember this period of time in which this kind of creative radio was just part of my life every single day. And so I really, really appreciate this project and what you're doing with it. It just, it just, it pleases me to no end. Oh, thank you. And I have to say, like, there's a lot out there besides audio flux. And that's what's very exciting about this moment is there are other independent small projects. There's Signal Hill. There's small audio art. There's in the dark. There are a lot of people out there who value hearing these and making this kind of work. So we feel like
喜欢闲聊的播客。我听长达三小时的播客。我制作并参与过那种特定的艺术形式。但能回忆起这段时期的感觉真是太好了，在这个时期，这种创意广播每天都是我生活的一部分。所以我真的非常感激这个项目以及你们在做的事情。这简直让我无比高兴。哦，谢谢你。我必须说，除了 AudioFlux，外面还有很多其他内容。而这个时刻最激动人心的地方就在于，还有其他独立的、小型项目。有 Signal Hill。有小型声音艺术。有 In the Dark。有很多人都珍视聆听这些内容并创作这种作品。所以我们觉得
we're part of a bit of a renaissance of, you know, audio for the sake of audio and community and culture alongside the podcast industry. So for people who want to get involved with AudioFlux, where can they find out more? Our website is the best place to sign up for our email list. We run two circuits a year, and every single person listening to this is very welcome to give it a go and submit to the next circuit, which should be launching at the end of February. And you do, but you do also have a podcast. So can you describe to your podcast? Oh, yeah. We have a podcast too. It's not exactly an afterthought, but it is, you know, one of the many parts of the project. So yes, yes, we launched our podcast, the AudioFlex podcast in the fall of last year. It's hosted by the marvelous Amy Pearl. And we are walking the walk. These episodes are maybe 10 minutes, 20 at the most. But really, we're keeping things short and just inviting people.
我们正在经历一场文艺复兴，你知道的，为了声音而声音的声音艺术，以及伴随播客行业而存在的社区和文化。那么对于想参与 AudioFlux 的人来说，他们可以在哪里了解更多信息呢？我们的网站是注册我们的电子邮件列表的最佳去处。我们每年举办两次循环活动，非常欢迎听这期节目的每一个人都来尝试一下，并向将于二月底推出的下一期循环活动提交作品。你们确实也做了一个播客。那么你能描述一下你们的播客吗？哦，是的。我们也有一个播客。它不完全是个事后诸葛亮的想法，但它确实是你所知道的该项目的众多组成部分之一。所以，是的，我们在去年秋天推出了我们的播客——AudioFlux 播客。它由了不起的艾米·珀尔（Amy Pearl）主持。我们正在切实践行。这些节目大概 10 分钟，最多 20 分钟。但实际上，我们将内容保持得很短，只是邀请大家
to just revel in what audio can do and celebrate these incredible creators that are, you know, experimenting and sending in their pieces. And, yeah, we're having a lot of fun with the podcast. And I hope everyone goes and subscribes for it. Julie Shapiro, thank you so much for talking with me. And thank you so much for audio flux. I really appreciate it. Oh, thanks, Roman. And, you know, you are also welcome to make a flux work anytime you would like to. I was so inspired listening to them that I really think that this is my year to get my audio flux out there. Okay, I'm holding you to that. You've basically signed on the dotted line. If you love these documentary stores and want to hear really short versions of 99% Invisible,
尽情享受声音所能做到的事情，并庆祝这些正在进行实验并提交作品的不可思议的创作者们。而且，是的，我们在做这个播客时玩得很开心。我希望每个人都去订阅它。朱莉·夏皮罗（Julie Shapiro），非常感谢你跟我交谈。也非常感谢你带来的 AudioFlux。我真的很感激。哦，谢谢你，罗曼。而且，你知道的，随时欢迎你创作 Flux 作品。听了这些作品，我深受启发，我真的认为今年是我把自己的 AudioFlux 作品推向世界的时候了。好的，我记住你的话了。你基本上已经签字画押了。如果你喜欢这些纪录片故事，并想听听 99% Invisible 的极简短版本，
the first 25 episodes of this show were all about five minutes or less. You can find those by scrolling way back in our feed or on our website, 99PI.org. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Jason DeLeon, mixed by Martine Gonzalez, music by Swan Real. Kathy, too, is our executive producer. Kirk Colsted is the digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Barube, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Lachamadon, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, Talon and Rain Stradley, and Me, Roman Mars.
这个节目的前 25 集时长都在五分钟或更短。你可以通过一直向下滚动我们的订阅源或访问我们的网站 99PI.org 来找到它们。本周的《99% Invisible》由杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon）制作，马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martine Gonzalez）混音，音乐由斯旺·里尔（Swan Real）创作。凯西·图（Kathy Tu）是我们的执行制片人。柯克·科尔斯特ッド（Kirk Colsted）是数字总监。德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是我们的高级编辑。团队其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Barube）、埃姆特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、薇薇安·李（Vivian Leigh）、拉克哈马登（Lachamadon）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、凯利·普赖姆（Kelly Prime）、雅各布·梅迪纳·格利森（Jacob Medina Gleason）、塔隆·雷恩·斯特拉德利（Talon and Rain Stradley），以及我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。
The 99% visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Serious XM Podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In Beautiful, Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《99% Invisible》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。我们是 Sirius XM 播客家族的一员，现在总部设在潘多拉大厦以北六个街区。位于美丽的上奥克兰市中心，加利福尼亚州。你可以在所有常用的社交媒体网站以及我们自己的 Discord 服务器上找到我们。在 99PI.org 上有一个指向该服务器以及 99PI 过去每一集节目的链接。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。